thomas denis on vous retrouve sur place
l'idée pour les russes et de consolider
leurs relations avec les indiens
oui cette visite du ministre des
affaires étrangères russe
a lieu dans un contexte où la russie est
quand même assez isolée sur l'a10 à
l'échelle diplomatique mondiale fait
face à des sanctions internationales et
donc assez logiquement le kremlin se
tourner vers ses partenaires à l'est
lavrov revient tout juste de chine et
c'est la première visite russe
d'importance en inde depuis le début de
la guerre et à vrai dire depuis quelques
semaines c'est l'effervescence
diplomatique à new delhi tout le monde a
un peu les yeux rivés sur la capitale
indienne le ministre des affaires
étrangères chinois est venu en inde
après trois ans sans visite récemment le
japon l'australie se sont aussi
entretenus avec new delhi et aujourd'hui
cette visite russe coïncide avec la
présence de dignitaires américains et
britanniques sur le sol indien et cette
visite de lavrov agace à vrai dire le
camp occidental notamment les états unis
qui ont répété à plusieurs reprises leur
déception quant à la position de
neutralité de new delhi et surtout son
abstention à plusieurs reprises pendant
les votes aux nations unies même si
l'inde s'est exprimé en faveur de cessez
le feu et de la paix à plusieurs
reprises et ce qui inquiète encore plus
aujourd'hui c'est le thème des
discussions qui devraient avoir lieu
entre entre la russie et l'inde on parle
on va parler de contrat d'armement entre
les deux pays d'approvisionnement en
pétrole russe à des prix avantageux pour
new delhi et surtout d'un système
alternatif de paiement avec des échanges
en roupies et en roubles pour contourner
les sanctions contre la russie et son
exclusion du système de paiement swift
donc l'une des questions qui se posent
actuellement c est ce que l'un d'eux va
intensifier ses échanges avec avec la
russie et aux yeux de ses partenaires
occidentaux ce serait une position loin
d'être neutre très rapidement thomas
s'il vous plaît comment expliquer cette
ambiguïté de l'inde vis-à-vis de la
guerre
l'un d'eux défend sa neutralité il ya
cette tradition de non-alignement depuis
depuis là depuis la guerre froide
aujourd'hui on parle plutôt de multi
alignement dans l'intérêt du son
continent l'inde dépend de la russie
pour son armement l'inde importe plus de
80% de son pétrole donc des prix
intéressants pourrait être aussi
avantageux pour la population et il ya
beaucoup de prix de préoccupations
géopolitiques avec cette peur de
l'encerclement et un rapprochement de la
chine avec la russie un rapprochement du
pakistan avec la russie n'est pas
possible pour pour new delhi parce que
la russie soutient new delhi sur le
groupe dossier du cachemire la chine
dernièrement à la frontière ça a été
très tendue avec l'inde est donc l'un
d'eux pas prendre de positions trop
ferme mais veut aussi en même temps
continuer avec ses alliés du pacifique
les américains les australiens le japon
pour continuer à peser face à la chine
et dans ce contexte l'un d'eux se
retrouve dans une position ultra
complexes et le monde a beaucoup
d'attentes beaucoup de pays notamment
l'ukraine aimerait que l'inde prennent
position profite de cette position
utilise la proximité pour jouer un rôle
de médiateur et poussé davantage vers
vers une issue vers vers la paix merci
beaucoup thomas denys en direct de new
delhi pour